hi alex
i have a business mentor who is telling
me that i should fake it until i make it
it sounds contrary to what you say on
your youtube channel and i don't know
who to trust and so i wanted to hear
your explanation for why you don't
believe in that concept
what's up everybody mozy nation rocking
and rolling my name is alex muzzy if
you're new to the channel
and we have a portfolio of companies
that does about 85 million dollars a
year and i have absolutely nothing to
sell you all right i make this channel
because a lot of people are broke and i
don't want you to be one of them so
welcome to moseynation all right so to
hit on this question right should i fake
it till i make it um this is something
that is really close to home for me uh
because i uh it drives me absolutely
bonkers and so i'll tell you a quick
story um and then and we can go from
there to illustrate the point so uh this
is probably five years ago maybe six
years ago somewhere in there um i was
showing up to our first event of our
licensees all right so we only had 28
licensee at the time and this is the
first event all right and as a side note
if you're curious why i have a mustache
this story will explain it to you so i
was so nervous the night before that i
for for the two-day event that we were
going to have to provide value and all
that kind of stuff
that i had this big beard and so i
shaved it off and i was doing you know
wolverine then mutton chops then
gunslinger and then all the way i had i
left down to a porn stash
and i look outside the bathroom and i
look at layla i was like hey baby um and
she cracked up and she was like please
don't do that i looked back in the
mirror and i cracked up and i was like
you know what i'm doing it i'm rocking
the stash and it's because i was so
nervous and so stressed about this day
tomorrow that i wanted to give myself a
reason to not just not take myself so
seriously right because i was like you
know what worst case scenario i'm gonna
die and no one's gonna remember who i am
anyways so anyways i show up the next
day and i pull up right as we're pulling
up to the hotel which is where the event
is right
and uh we're pulling up in a prius that
has a dent in the side and a crack in
the windshield and one of licensees
comes up to me
and uh and she says
and as she's walking at the same time
and sees that so she stops and walks
over and
she says hey uh i thought you were
supposed to be rich
and you can imagine the terror right
because this is the you know impostor
syndrome that i'm dealing with the night
before right now mind you at this point
i already had six gyms we sold them and
then i'd already had 30 plus turnarounds
right so like i was very good at the
thing that we're talking about right but
i still have this i still remember the
the shock but what i said next is the
reason that i have always been
transparent with my numbers when we do
well when we not do well in terms of how
we do our lifestyle et cetera all right
and so at the time i was a cash
millionaire so a million dollars in my
bank account right and i hadn't even
started investing stuff yet so side note
i think making sure you have the right
sequence is important but a million
dollars saved up in my bank account
after taxes at this moment
and when she said this i just remember
thinking i was like oh my god am i a
fraud and then the reality of my
situation not the fakeness of my
situation
was what came forth to hold me strong in
that moment and i said
you should see my bank account not my
car
and i was like i'm all i was like you
want to be rich not not look rich right
she was like yeah and i was like well
that's what i'm here to show you how to
do and then the rest the event was
awesome and then all the people two
weeks later all the dudes had stashes
without me saying anything so i think
they liked it and then that is what gave
birth to the stash which you know has
still still been pervasive in many of
the marketing things that we've done all
right but here's the reason that i'm i'm
i'm actually against the fake it so you
make it the first is that you in the
mirror at night know that you're a fraud
i mean and that's the biggest thing at
the end of the day if you've heard
anything that i've ever talked about is
that you have to have conviction in what
you sell right and the the thing at the
very most that you are selling is you
are selling yourself to yourself and if
you are lying
to everyone else about how successful
you are
then you're trying you're you're
cheating you're you're deceiving
yourself and that kind of integrity is
very hard to recapture because the
hardest person's respect to earn is your
own in my opinion right once you have
your own respect everyone else's respect
comes pretty easily because they know
that you respect you and so i know this
is deep stuff but like at the end of the
day like entrepreneurship is is a
journey of beliefs right it's a journey
about building your character
and about acquiring skills and the
businesses are only a reflection or a
manifestation of the internal changes
that we've had or experienced as
entrepreneurs which is why i think
entrepreneurship is the single greatest
personal development path you can
possibly go on here's some other reasons
why i think this is stupid and mind you
at the time when i had a million dollars
my bank account lail and i were living
together
on 1200 a month of rent and about 400
ish a month in food so 100 bucks a week
in food 1200 a month in rent and that's
what we were living on and we were
taking home at the time three or four
hundred thousand a month all right so
just for context i'm just and i i've
never had a really expensive watch the
only really expensive thing that i've
purchased uh that was a waste was a
bentley which i actually already sold
and gave it away i'm sure i could come
up with some sexy youtube headline for
that but
we just gave it back because i didn't
need it and i didn't want it it felt
like a waste and it felt contrary to who
i am and what i believe it right at the
end of the day if you decide what your
values are first and you live your life
in accordance with those values rather
than what you think the world wants you
to do then you will be able to stand
steadfast and strong in the face of
adversity with full knowledge of who you
are and i think that the strength of
that cannot be understated i've said
this quote many times in our communities
and on this channel which is you must
outwork yourself doubt right if you feel
like you are not confident then you must
outwork the things that you're insecure
about if you're like man i'm selling
these services and i don't show i'm not
sure if i'm not good at them then do
more of them and don't pretend
honesty is one of the most compelling
and convicting things for persuading
people right saying what you are good at
and what you are not good at truthfully
will win you far more followers and fans
and and loyal customers and loyal
employees than pretending because the
end of the day they can feel that you
are disingenuous because they know that
is hollow they know that the inside you
do not believe the words that are coming
out of your mouth and that is how people
speak without conviction and they cannot
sway others because they have not swayed
themselves because they have lost their
own respect and so i am not the believer
in buying the ferrari when you can't
afford it i am not the believer in in
affording the home and paying for the
home
that you cannot afford because you want
to pretend like this is the lifestyle
that you want to be around if you go
under the guise of networking you can
still go to those places without buying
a four million dollar house when you
you're barely making you know a few
hundred thousand dollars a year it
doesn't make sense i like jay-z's quote
around this which is if you can't buy
something twice don't buy it once i
really like that and so
this is one of the most common questions
i get for newer entrepreneurs because
they think that they have to they have
to they have to pose on instagram in
order to get to get wealthy and what it
does is it conflates sequence jeff bezos
is famous because of what he did not
because he became famous as jeff bezos
and then used his following to build
something elon musk is famous for what
he's accomplished not for being elon
musk and then creating something as a
result right let the actions be the
thing that gives you the fame rather
than yourself right at least that is
that is alex's two cents in my viewpoint
on the world and i think most of those
mozi nation you guys uh share that
belief with me and for those of you who
are new to this channel um you're gonna
get more of this type of stuff uh and
none of the fake it till you make it
nonsense that is a sure way uh to be
broke and i will tell you this as a last
thing
the amount of people who in 2008 when
everything crashed who were faking it
until they quote made it
just faked it until they lost it all
because they lost what little amount
that they had because they were so
overextended but i can tell you that
just about everyone can become wealthy
if you choose to live on lower on less
than you make right and that is a ratio
wealth is a ratio not a number all right
and so anywho uh if you are having
struggles with this question i would
posit i would i would beg of you
that you build your own respect first
that you're honest with yourself first
and if you always maintain the integrity
of hey last year we we got smashed right
this year we'll do a little bit better
and two years from now when you do even
better than that you can be truthful and
people will believe you but if you
always are telling a story about how
you're always doing so well
a everyone will hate you b no one cares
and c
you will know that you are full of it
and at the end of the day i think that
is the only thing that we're going to
keep with us and when we die everyone's
going to forget about us anyways so you
might as well at least enjoy yourself
while you're alive so anyways keep being
awesome was your nation if you enjoyed
this subscribe if you did lots of love
either way keeping awesome i'll catch
you next videos bye